Nostalgia depression and Cinema's
greatest imaginary friend it's time to
take a journey Inside the Mind of Riley
Anderson who knows you might even learn
something about your own mind inside out
is centered around the hectic Mind of a
child and much of the plot involves
tackling the emotional disarray that
characterizes that period of life but
the film also takes the time to hop into
the heads of the other people around
Riley such as her parents when we get a
glimpse into their headquarters some
interesting details are revealed about
the way maturity affects the mind in the
minds of both Riley's mother and father
the emotions operate as a much more
cohesive team sitting together around a
larger control panel accessed by every
emotion the emotions work in tandem too
with each one contributing a little to
any given situation in sharp contrast to
the incessant Scramble for control going
on inside Riley's head even the emotions
themselves are shown to be more
level-headed in the adults heads while
their equivalents in Riley's mind are
shown to be driven by their respective
emotions most of the time the emotions
and her parents headquarters are
depicted more like professionals this
doesn't mean that adults aren't prone to
impulsive outbursts but it does mean
that they they've learned to manage
those impulses over time the question of
which emotion is dominant in
headquarters proves to be much more
crucial for a child since only one
emotion can operate the controls of the
time indeed it's Joy's autocratic
Central role that eventually causes
everything to fall apart you can't focus
on what's going wrong there's always a
way to turn things around to find the
fun in adults meanwhile it appears that
there is a central emotion at
headquarters but they're more of a team
coordinator making sure everybody's
actions are aligned it's never confirmed
if the emotions sitting that the center
of an adult control panel is constant or
changes from moment to moment as the
situation dictates but whatever the case
the emotions in charge of Riley's
parents are very revealing in her
mother's mind the leader is sadness
which makes perfect sense for an adult
who is currently experiencing a
Melancholy life change and constantly
Fring over her family's emotional
well-being sadness is after all the
emotion that powers empathy Riley's
father meanwhile is having his emotions
coordinated by anger which is also a
very understandable adult response to
the series of setbacks and logistical
issues he's having to deal with at home
and work inside out's message
essentially states that all emotions
have their place in a person's
development including sadness but a more
season viewer might also notice that the
film goes beyond that message and even
enters more incisive thematic territory
in the way that it analyzes the role of
joy in Riley's mind Joy is undeniably at
fault for suppressing Riley's more
negative and nuanced emotions and an
attempt to keep her happy 100% of the
time but pay closer attention to the
character's actions and their
consequences in the film specifically
the way that Joy keeps desperately rep
play in Riley's old happy memories when
she's reacting to the move to San
Francisco because it's difficult for
Riley to find things to be happy about
in her new situation her mind keeps
clinging to Old bygone sources of Joy
but those memories can't do anything for
Riley in the present except remind her
that things are not the way she wants by
resorting to Nostalgia Riley makes it
harder to process her current situation
and in failing to process it she loses
any chance of forming any new happy
memories arguably the most heartbreaking
moment in the movie comes when sadness
takes over Riley's headquarters just as
she's returning home to her parents
resulting in a long overdue emotional
breakdown that finally allows them to
understand her pain the fact that
Riley's control panel was turning gray
and inoperable before that moment has
been widely interpreted as a metaphor
for depression she's only able to break
out of this when she accepts and
surrenders to the sadness her mind has
been trying to suppress it's an
incredibly potent Insight but the film's
depression metaphor runs even deeper
than that essentially Riley's depression
is a result of dysfunctional emotional
processing her mind cannot deal with all
the feelings that come with moving to
San Francisco she may have been a very
happy kid before but her happiness her
sense of self and her relationship with
life were all contingent on external
circumstances that no longer exist never
before had she been cast so helplessly
into a situation that left her so
vulnerable to fear rage repulsion and
confusion as a result she shuts down
emotionally because her mind doesn't
know what else to do what have we done
it's only by accepting and moving
through the pain that she's able to
break out of that defensive apathy and
feel again in the credits we get an
insight into the headquarters of other
minor characters in the film and each
one reveals something amusing about the
character in question Riley's school
teacher depicted in about a frustrated
boredom and her students disinterest in
her class is shown to be led by Joy this
may seem odd at first but it makes sense
the ability to remain cheerful makes for
an indispensable tool in a middle school
teacher's Arsenal the perpetually
annoyed cashier at the pizza place is
managed by disgust which tracks with her
dry attitude toward her customers since
disgust is the emotion of Social and
aesthetic judgment it's also no surprise
that someone who has to deal with
customers all day would default to being
led by it a cool girl at Riley school is
of course ruled by the constant fear she
has of being exposed as a fraud we even
get a glimpse into the real life Jangles
a clown who despite hating his job is
ruled by Joy a nice rhyme with the
school teacher as they're both adults
whose professional lives revolve around
keeping kids entertained and engaged
when joy and sadness lost somewhere in
the recesses of Riley's mind it's up to
fear disgust and anger to run
headquarters in their absence at one
point fear gives up trying to salvage
Riley's emotional state and attempts to
quit leaving headquarters through the
same tube that sucked up Joy and sadness
emotions can't quit genius the emotions
can't quit but joy and sadness were very
much removed from headquarters which was
functionally identical to What Fear
tried to do this seems to suggest two
things the first is that while emotions
can be accidentally ejected from
headquarters an emotion can't
voluntarily self- eject our feelings
might get messy for any number of
reasons but we're not allowed to choose
which ones we get rid of the second is
that fear can't remove itself from our
minds out of well fear there's an
argument to be made that fear is the
most Prim of all human emotions the base
instinct to evade danger and keep
ourselves alive and healthy we can block
out our sadness our anger and even our
joy but fear isn't something that can be
suppressed it's always there to some
degree an omnipresent participant in
decision-making processes Inside Out may
be a kids movie but it's also a Pixar
movie and as such it makes at least a
couple of adult-oriented jokes in this
case many of them revolve around San
Francisco the maddening traffic the
apathetic cashier with the purple side
cuts and the broccoli Pizza are the
obvious gags but the funny funniest joke
is arguably the one that's most
expressly designed to go over kids'
heads what was that was it a bear it's a
bear there are no bears in San Francisco
I saw a really hairy guy he looked like
a bear to some extent a guy so hairy he
looks like a bear is technically
descriptive enough to work as a joke
even if you're unfamiliar with a certain
terminology but what's funny about the
joke is a reference to the San Francisco
lgbtq plus community and specifically to
the concept of bears which is gay slang
for plus-sized hairy guys if you're an
adult who's aware of the city's status
as a worldwide Capital the mere
suggestion that there are no bears in
San Francisco will be enough to get you
giggling there are several references
and inside out that children would be
very unlikely to get heck some of the
references are esoteric enough that even
adult viewers might not pick up on them
at first the most memorable one is
arguably the Chinatown shout out while
two security guards are trying to solve
the case of a cloud man who was blown
away by Bing Bong Joy dashes right
through the cloud man's wife as she's
giving testimony was he with anyone yes
and there she is hey come back here
forget it Jake it's Cloud town this of
course is a hilariously over-the-top nod
to The Bleak ending of the classic 1974
detective film forget it Jake it's China
Town at another point to enjoy sadness
in bing bong or walking through the
dream Productions lot they pass a poster
for a film titled I'm falling for a very
long time into a pit this is a clear
parody of sa bass's iconic poster for
vertigo a 1958 film in which James
Stewart's character has a nightmare
about just that when a major character
in a movie has a big tear-jerking death
scene like that suffered by bing bong
and inside out the story will usually
later take a moment to memorialize or
mourn that character in some way in this
film however the characters never
acknowledge Bing Bong after he
sacrifices himself to help joy to escape
the memory dump when he's forgotten by
Riley and Fades away it seems like the
movie forgets about him as well this is
a decision that may feel odd and
unsatisfying especially for younger
viewers but adult viewers will
understand exactly why the movie depicts
Bing bong's demise that way the very
source of melancholy underlining Bing
Bong as a character is the fact that
he's an anachronism a relic of Early
Childhood with no place in an older mind
he's a walking reminder that childhood
ends and never comes back and once it's
gone it's also largely forgotten all the
ideas and imaginative Adventures that
make up each child's own Universe fade
away after a while they're not mourned
they're not ulize they're not missed
they just go and so does Bing Bong a key
plot point in the film is the fact that
sadness is extremely knowledgeable about
Riley's mind this is why Joy relies on
her to guide them through the vast
Realms outside headquarters the
groundwork for this is laid when sadness
reveals that she has read almost all of
the Mind manuals dozens of dense toes
detailing the mind's workings and the
way that memories are processed and
stored long-term memory data selection
via Channel subgrouping see fun already
oh you lucky dog you're reading these
cool things I got to go work while this
may appear to be a mere joke about the
fact that sadness is left out of
headquarters operations and ends up
reading a lot to pass the time a closer
reading reveals something crucial about
the film's themes sadness isn't just key
to fostering empathy and understanding
between people it's also key to self-
understanding as adults know sadness is
the emotion most likely to be conducive
to self-analysis and introspection poets
and philosophers alike have described
sadness as the emotion of the resilient
the mark of those capable of facing The
Human Condition head on no wonder
sadness knows the rules of Riley's mind
so well she's the only one who has
bothered to have a look at them and
without sadness Joy could never have
found her way through Riley's mind at
the end of inside out it's implied that
Riley has attained the hard-earned gift
of emotional complexity she can now
produce Blended memories and her
expanded control panel suggests that her
emotions will finally be able to start
working together but that's not the end
of the movie's message about the
interplay between emotions it doesn't
seem to be a coincidence that Joy is the
only emotion that features another
emotion's color in her design deep blue
in her hair and eyes she's also the only
one who experiences another emotion
besides her own to a blatant degree if
Riley's Early Childhood was spent
clinging to Joy to the detriment of
other emotions Joy realizes that as
maturity comes knocking she'll have to
start getting used to Sadness the film's
ultimate Point appears to be that as a
person grows up there comes a point when
Joy can only really exist in so far as
sadness does there's inherent loneliness
and despair in The Human Condition a
fear of loss and displacement that
follows us all through adulthood but
there's also joy and that Joy comes as a
direct result of sadness once we stop
taking our lives for granted the good
things become even more special and
beautiful exactly because they're finite
and rare Joy learns this Riley learns
this and sadness is right there to help
guide them through whatever comes next
heavy stuff for a kids
movie